[Music]
how are you
i'm good so i recently watched the movie
and i
loved it i loved it so much
but you know now i have a few questions
that i really want to ask
first questions from a cat so you know
jack's losing his arms is like one of
the pinnacles of his origin story so
could you like
walk through what was it like for you
filming the scene that sub-zero freezes
and destroys your arms
um so i mean i'm not sure if there's any
particular canon of how jack loses his
arms he loses several different ways in
the games right but um
so um
[Music]
it as an actor
uh
i made the mistake of
watching
joe taslim in a movie called the raid
the night before we had to fight
so
i didn't sleep the night before
because
[Laughter]
i mean i was like i gotta fight this guy
and so like
the fight scenes are really really
intricate and like louis to tell you
like our fight scenes like take a week
like
five minutes is like a week right so joe
and i got to know each other really well
and very intimately in the fight scene
and like
my nervousness kind of left in the
beginning and like joe was like you know
we're doing the choreography and like
joe just
makes it seem like a dance and so and it
is a dance and it's like so when you're
watching joe tasman do a fight scene
it's like watching michael jackson in
his prime up close
right so
that's that's what i can tell you about
the fight scene um
i lost my voice with all the yelling and
like
you know the the intensity of like
losing the arms i thought my eyes were
gonna pop out of my head and my voice
was gone for about a week but
you do what you do
perfect it looked absolutely painful um
you're playing an original character so
i like your co-stars you don't really
have a history to lean on when you're
playing your role
who or what were your inspirations when
portraying cole
well cole is a character that
starts off in a very interesting
position in his life where he feels lost
he feels like he's missed an opportunity
he's missed a shot he's uh not living up
to his full potential and i think that
that's something that's very relatable
to a lot of people um myself included
you know immortal combat
talent will only get you so far
um feeling like you have to prove
yourself feeling like
you know you're not good enough and no
one's giving you this chance and you
know you had this opportunity and now
it's gone and maybe you're never gonna
have it again and you know as an actor
and as a as an asian actor especially
you you always have those kind of
emotions so
i pulled a lot from some real parts of
who i am and then also
um
cole
his fighting style as an mma so he has
he's a mixed martial artist and um as a
martial artist myself i pull a lot from
you know my old senseis and you know my
training um and then there's a ufc
fighter named uh jorge mazvidal who used
to be a bare knuckle backyard boxer um
then now he's one of the best ufc
fighters in the world and um he has a
really cool physicality about him and um
kind of like a salt of the earth
grittiness about him and i took the body
language um from him uh so that's the
inspiration for the character and
there's many other things too but i
can't give away all my secrets
okay i love that gotta watch the movie
definitely gonna ask people to watch the
movie but you know
you guys okay this game is called guess
what's next um it's just a short clip
and you kind of guess what's happening
next
[Music]
yeah i know what happens um it's well
it's a home run like he like like he
gets the head back and then uses the arm
for it i call that lending me a hand
though
yup
all right you got it all right
all righty
oh my god
wow
what i don't know i i don't know this
one because i haven't seen uh his
fatalities yet but i'm assuming that
there's some sort of time portal that's
gonna occur and then i'm assuming that
there's some sort of horrific thing
that's gonna happen with the shotgun
let's see i'm gonna say i'm gonna say
liquid steel
oh wow you're right
i was close
han yeah it's amazing
okay
yeah go ahead guys
somebody sold by the good jack
yeah he's gonna turn in yeah someone's
soul's gonna get sucked he's about to
turn into something different
um and now chinh han from singapore
knows this answer but it looks it looks
he looks so much like china it's crazy
you shouldn't kill that
oh friendship
again wow
i like that you got me on that one now
that's that's the cod's favorite
fatality by the way
yes
yes
taste the
rainbow car is all about peace and love
so that's that's that's not very much
like that one or the other jack
saxophone yeah okay
[Music]
i think i think you should play a
different instrument but that's his name
oh my god i actually have many more but
we have to go i think that's all the
time i have with you i'm so sad but that
was fun
it's fun
thank you so much i appreciate it i'm
glad you liked the film
yeah thank you